[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be doing a very special
take right now we're gonna be talking
about what I call my manifesto it's
something that I wrote just last night
it's very short and it's kind of
essential thesis to the book that I'm
writing about time so what I have here
is I have this very short document and
I'll be releasing this document along
with this video at the same time as both
the blog post and as a video and be
sharing those now let's go through the
title quick this is very important and
dear to me what is time Perret Oh
efficiencies mimetics are greater than
genetics and the second Gutenberg
Revolution alright so we'll break all of
those down as we go through this very
short write-up blog post thesis and I'll
be going to what I've pulled up ask some
very solid visual guides along the way
as we go so stick so stick with me this
is gonna be a lot of fun and they'll be
very consciousness expanding all right
so let's start here I started off with
what is time right so this is a really
good way to understand it once you're
birthed into the world you have about
and this is into the developed world
right that you have about two and a half
billion seconds or about thirty thousand
days to live as your lifespan that's
about eighty two years or so and that's
in the developed world because in the
undeveloped world is still less than
that now if time is so limited to the
extent of it's just thirty thousand days
just two and a half billion seconds
and that's ironically also about the
same amount of base pairs that we have
in our genome very similar comparisons
that I've written about as well that the
earth surface area is 70% water and our
bodies are 70% water that an atom is
99.999% space and a solar system with
planet and star is also 99.99% space so
if time is so precious to us because
it's so short in the sense then
shouldn't we be as vigilant as possible
with the way that we pass our time now
of course this is pending life extension
technology we know that many people are
working on extending our lifespans and
then we will have more time but with
what we have right now with what we're
guaranteed right now in the developed
world what can we do in these 82 years
to maximize our own potential and
maximize the potential of the collective
all right and this has to do with what
we do every single day all right so as
we go down we explore that I write here
a major key is applying the Pareto
principle to minute to minimize noise an
increase signal when it comes to
knowledge and people networks okay so
good question what is the Pareto
principle alright so in order to explain
that what I've pulled up here is I've
pulled up the Wikipedia of Pareto
principle it's also known as the 80/20
rule and here I'm gonna do a little zoom
for us and make it easy to read Pareto
principle also known as the 80/20 rule
initially discovered by Italian
economist vilfredo pareto this was about
in
18:18 yeah 1890 or so states that for
many events roughly 80% of the effects
come from 20% of the causes okay meaning
for example vilfredo pareto showed that
approximately 80% of the land in Italy
was owned by 20% of the population okay
there's so many more examples of this
even to the extent at which Richard
talked here it's an axiom
of business management that 80% of sales
come from 20% of clients and this is so
relatable to us so many of us work in
businesses and we know that only 20% of
our total clients bring us 80% of our
revenue and those are the really
important connections that we have to
foster and grow and blossom over time so
this idea applies to so many different
things including here listen this one's
good the p-pods
the vital few people's produce the
majority of peas but check this one out
down here this is the distribution of
world GDP and it follows the perfect
Pareto distribution here period o
principle check this out the richest 20%
of people in the world have about 82
percent of income meanwhile the bottom
80% right here have somewhere around the
other 18 percent or so okay so that
gives us a decent idea about the Pareto
principle all right so now when it comes
to knowledge and people networks we have
to think about it this way we have a
ubiquity in knowledge and people
networks it
a myriad there's so much to parse it's
overwhelming superfluous so what we can
do is we can go and parse for the
highest Pareto efficiencies in the
amount of knowledge in the people
networks that exist so this means that
what knowledge that exists in the world
what 20% of the knowledge that exists in
the world is gonna give me 80% of a
total understanding of reality what 20%
of my network of people networks are
gonna bring me 80% of the important
value that I need to both give them and
that they need to give me in order to
flourish okay so this has to also be
addressed by saying the second sentence
here which is technology's incredible
but also it's causing the age of
distraction impeding people's ability to
focus execute and parse for
signal-to-noise so we have amazing
widespread technology so incredible but
it is distracting us it's taking us away
from achieving our goals because we can
no longer focus the attention economy
has us reeled
like this and it's killing us we need to
parse for signal we need to find the
signal and I'll get to why hint
geopolitical leadership I'll get there
all right this is really interesting
this is a very cybernetics take this
next part that I wrote here one's
network can be viewed as genetic
expressions where it's important to turn
off less Pareto efficient genes and turn
on those that are assisting us in
climbing the genetic fitness landscape
there is a genetic fitness landscape
there is competence hierarchies these
are true existing things so in
for us to achieve our goals as fast as
possible we want to surround ourselves
with other people that know how to
execute and make things into the world
and impact people positively so we have
to open up our genetic expressions and
turn them on to those people that are
building the future and that can help
elevate us and we can elevate them and
turn off the genetic expressions to
others that we can't invest our time to
in order for us to be more focused with
our time be more Pareto efficient with
our time all right so that's kind of an
interesting cybernetics take with
biology and with with Pareto
efficiencies in networks in using time
and in knowledge all right so now let's
go a little bit a little bit further
with this so I want to I do want us to
make sure that we touch on Pareto
efficiency with the with like a visual
here that I think makes it pretty easy
to understand but this is again the out
right here Preda optimality or
efficiency allocation of resources from
which it is impossible to relocate so
ask to make any one individual or
preference criterium better off without
making at least one or one individual or
preference criterion worse off okay like
we said you're going to take someone
that is that you can be better off with
and you're going to invest more time
into them which means you can't invest
time into the people that you're turning
your genetic expressions off with and
again this is a good graph to look at it
right here
quantity of item one quantity of item
two here you're being Pareto efficient
with quantity item two with a little bit
of quantity item one here you're being
Pareto efficient with lots of quantity
item one but very little of quantity
item two here all right so jumping back
all right so
now geopolitical leadership all right
why geopolitical leadership important
there's so much nuance and multivariable
'ti that needs to be unpacked when it
comes to geopolitical leadership we live
on a very small rock this is a very very
small earth it only takes about 40 days
to sail around the earth 40 days
proof right here here's proof around the
world in 42 days Frenchman sets new
sailing record this happened at the end
of last year this is what's called a
trimaran right here this is a trimaran
and so he went by himself and sailed for
42 days and this is around the Roaring
Forties which is on the southern
hemisphere for earth between 40 and 50
degrees latitude where there's only
words to swear it's 17 to 27 mile an
hour winds there's no land masses
blocking it and you've sailed around 42
days this is a small earth what other
evidence do we need that it's a very
small earth well how about the fact that
it only takes one day to fly around
earth it only takes about one day to fly
around earth you can get there in a
little bit longer depending on which
plane you take a little bit shorter
depending on which plane you take but
about one day to fly around it even
crazier it only takes 90 minutes to
orbit Earth in the International Space
Station 90 minutes every 90 minutes the
International Space Station orbits earth
this is a small place this is a small
place all right so us monkeys need to
work together we need to figure out how
to work together so that we can make it
to the next rocks and that we can
prosper together all right
so in order to sit at the table of
guiding civilizational trajectory one
must form hyperino efficiency advances
so what we're describing earlier in
neural architecture at the youngest age
as possible and throughout life okay
what
that mean let's unpack that a little so
what do I mean by these highest Pareto
efficiencies at the youngest ages
possible with the formation of neural
architecture well think about this
you're born into the world and you have
this time two and a half billion seconds
or thirty thousand days the earlier that
you can start applying the Pareto
principle to knowledge and to people
networks and surrounding yourself with
the highest quality knowledge and the
highest quality people and in making
your neurons and your neural
infrastructure form at the youngest age
possible to maximize the potential for
you to be able to sit at the table of
geopolitical leadership guiding the
trajectory of civilization that is
important that is important and keeping
that same mentality throughout life all
right so let's jump into this next part
fertility rates trend to below
replacement in developed countries
global population looks to stabilize
then decrease okay let's have a visual
for this all right so right here what we
see are we see we see we see fertility
rates total fertility rates all right so
total fertility rate that was the
meditation notification who have to do
that later
so total fertility rates as you can see
here we have the more developed a nation
becomes the lower their fertility rate
becomes so prior to the world being a
developed place fertility words were
really high we had to have lots of kids
because some were dying or at earlier
ages some weren't making a child
mortality was higher disease was higher
infant mortality all these things were
higher in the past and we needed more
people on the farms and we needed and we
needed more people working with us and
now we don't we don't this is a really
interesting point you see here US Canada
Brazil Russia so much of Europe China
Australia it's crazy how much India is
now at
two two three as well so much of Earth
is now going below replacement fertility
so you know if you we only have one kid
per two people where our population is
going to let's come back this and you
can see Africa still has a little bit
they're still developing so they still
have in some places six kids but that's
going to change very soon as well so so
as you as you see here more and more
people are choosing to have less
children many people are finding meaning
and responsibility in their lives by
building something of utility into our
world
so if global if global population
stabilizes stabilizes it's increasing
then stabilizes and decreases over time
now more and more people choose to find
meaning and responsibility in their
lives by building something of utility
into our world okay so maybe it's
possible that mimetics that this
cultural information transfer right here
cultural information transfer amplified
by technological progress has the
propensity to mold the ways of thinking
of billions of people which can be
viewed as a more efficient way of
guiding civilization than having
children so you want to sit at this
table and you want to guide the
trajectory of civilization it is more
important to focus on mimetics and the
cultural transfer of information than it
is to produce an offspring and focus on
genetics although children do bring lots
of meaningful film into life alright so
how are we to do this a quantum assault
II disciplinary multivariate
conversation will help us morally guide
us through existential risk wealth
inequality sustainable colonization of
the cosmos now let's unpack Aquin enmity
staying even keel alright
staying calm staying composed that's
what equanimity is we can be excited
whoa and we can also be meditative but
we calm and composed okay also
multidisciplinary being able to take
knowledge from different fields and
combine it together and make really
interesting points multi
taking different variables and
understanding things aren't binary
alright and the morality of getting
through existential risk we have
biowarfare we have artificial general
intelligence we have wealth and equality
we have all these things that are coming
a forth that we need to be sure that we
do not die from nuclear war asteroid
strikes we need to become interplanetary
and then enter solar multiplanetary
interstellar we need to get there and
get there quickly it's our big picture
vision to colonize the cosmos
sustainably and this idea of the earth
being so connected right here look at
this this is a hundred thousand flights
are taken every single day across the
world this is the most connected we've
ever been in our lives on this planet
and so now in order for us to shift our
mentality and get out this is a
beautiful photo that was taken by the
Hubble of another galaxy that galaxy
looks gorgeous I want to explore it I
want to explore the planets and I think
it's gonna expand our minds to need
dimensions once we get away from this
solar system to other ones and start
expanding exploring and understanding
this better so all right this is being
vigilant about spending time this is the
second Gutenberg Revolution this is
guiding the trajectory of civilization
to prosperity this is the again vigilant
about spending time this is the second
Guttenberg Revolution and this is
guiding the trajectory of civilization
to prosperity how can you become more
Pareto efficient let's get there
together be vigilant about the way we
spend our time such little time we have
second Gutenberg Revolution we have the
digital age that is exploded now and hit
billions of people with your cultural
information transfer and this is guiding
the trajectory of civilization to
prosperity let's be at that table of
guiding trajectory let's get to that
table and let's fight hard so that we
can get
there and work together to get there and
move forward so become more Preta
efficient find out the knowledge and the
people networks that you need to turn on
and the ones that you need to turn off
form the minds of youth into the world
to also see this as of the reality much
love thank you very much for tuning in
again this has been a little bit about
time Perret Oh efficiencies mimetics
genetics second Gutenberg Revolution
guys this is the kind of stuff that I'm
in love with this is the kind of stuff
that you're gonna get from me as we
continue growing simulation and growing
our impact we are reversing the public
intellectual we are inspiring you to
build the future and we are going to
fill sports stadiums for full-day
multidisciplinary events join us YouTube
Facebook patreon come and support us
let's get there together let's prosper
baby thank you for tuning in much love
peace so I'll be on the books soon
[Music]
[Music]